[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce jeu vous nouveau journal
d'information locale nous sommes le
lundi 27 septembre voici les titres de
cette édition
les dates de l'espoir se sont déroulés
ce week-end objectif lutter contre la
mucoviscidose sensibiliser et récolter
des fonds franck berger organisateurs de
la virade des rois à
saint-germain-en-laye sera avec nous en
plateau le bilan dans cette édition et
puis un baby sitting dating a pris place
à montigny le bretonneux samedi un
événement pour faire rencontrer les
parents et jeunes baby sitter nous
reviendrons sur la difficulté de faire
garder ses enfants avec awa camara
directrice de la crèche la bei et le
papillon à montigny
[Musique]
et le ministre délégué chargé des
transports jean baptiste djebbari s'est
rendu le vendredi 24 septembre sur le
site de style en tice motorsport à
versailles-satory un déplacement sur la
thématique de la technologie électrique
dans le sport automobile avec notamment
la formule eu un reportage ni cola
d'andy et michael et demi d'euros
une immersion dans une formule
électrique ds automobile sur le circuit
du grand prix de monaco l'expérience
proposée au ministre délégué en charge
des transports jean baptiste djebbari un
essai notamment pour comprendre le
fonctionnement de la technologie
électrique dans le sport automobile est
vraiment tout un travail autour de mon
du pilotage lieu et un gros travail que
j'ignorais en tout cas dont je n'avais
pas complètement compris l'ampleur sur
la gestion d'énergie l'idée étant
d'utiliser l'énergie à bord pour
partiellement la régénérer pendant la
course et donc finir avec
le minimum d'électricité mais finir
quand même ce simulateur de formule
électrique est située sur le site sté
lantiss motorsport à versailles-satory
un outil destiné aux pilotes pour
l'entraînement et la préparation des
courses chaque pilote fasse de l'ordre
de 5 jours ici sur le site a préparé la
course avant chaque événement
une semaine avant avant la course ils
viennent ici pour s'entraîner et
préparer les courses réviser les
stratégies apprendre les circuits
travailler avec leurs ingénieurs pour
arriver aussi près que possible sur le
sur l'événement de la course ce site du
groupe issu de la fusion entre psa et
fiat chrysler est spécialisée dans le
sport automobile 230 personnes
travaillent ici de la formule eds
automobile au programme d'endurance de
peugeot sport avec une stratégie
orientée de plus en plus vers
l'électrique l'objectif c'est vraiment
d'appuyer d'appuyer la formule
électrique qui est qui a pour objectif
de développer la l'électrification de
l'automobile en général la spécificité
des courses électrique c'est plutôt des
courses urbaines sur les temps assez
court 45 minutes donc avec des vitesses
moyennes un peu un peu inférieur à ce
qu'on connaît en formule 1 donc on n'est
pas tout à fait le même registre de
course mais en tout cas ça porte sur le
plan du développement et des
applications sur les véhicules de série
ça porte ses fruits ds automobile
deviendra une marque 100 % électrique à
partir de 2024
le dimanche 26 septembre se sont
déroulées les virades de l'espoir
un événement national pour lutter contre
la mucoviscidose c'est une maladie
génétique non contagieuse qui touche
principalement les voies respiratoires
respiratoires et le système digestif et
dont on ne connaît pas aujourd'hui elle
prend deux bergers vous êtes avec nous
ou bonsoir jour justine donc dans les
yvelines il ya deux virages cette année
il y en avait deux une hache voisine à
saint germain en laye et vous vous êtes
l'organisateur de la virade donc des
rois et qui a pris place dans le parc du
château de saint-germain-en-laye
plusieurs défis ce week-end donc
dimanche sportif notamment qu'elle était
programme sur place alors c'était la 22e
virades des rois à saint germain en laye
on avait un programme éclectique avec
des défis sportifs et notamment sur
tapis roulant on avait fait les
dernières sous peu vide un seul défi est
là ont retrouvé le public en trouver les
bénévoles ont trouvé les familles que
c'était assez émouvant de ce point de
vue là et puis il y avait la marque de
fabrique de la virade des rois saint
germain il y avait les baptêmes en
voitures anciennes en harley davidson et
puis il y avait des animations aussi
pour les enfants avec
le parcours du souffle et puis il y
avait des marches une marche sportive le
matin et les marges commenté justement
vous parlez du parcours du souffle on
avait venu en fête dimanche donner son
souffle c'est symbolique oui c'était
très symbolique c'est ont à chaque fois
soit on court avec un triathlon on a
fait des courses là cette année c'était
en fait un défi fallait faire plus de
150 km sur des tapis roulants et donc
symboliquement il fallait venir donner
son souffle et donc c'est ce qu'on fait
des centaines de personnes à saint
germain en laye sur le domaine national
et dans le parc du château ils trouvent
des centaines de personnes le public les
événements en tout cas étaient présents
ils se sont mobilisés dimanche oui c'est
assez émouvant effectivement on sentait
une volonté de retrouver en fait cette
ce contact 22 ans à saint germain en
laye sa marque et donc les illinois et
les singes à un manhwa son sont vraiment
très présents et ont peu répondu présent
fait dimanche le temps était quand même
de la partie il ya même si on a eu
quelques gouttes l'après midi donc oui
et donc on a battu effectivement
l'objectif qu'on s'était donné puisqu'on
a fait 174 km en tapis roulants des
trois tapis roulant qui étaient là n'ont
pas arrêté de la journée donc objectif
rempli pour donner son souffle 174km pas
mal au niveau des dons combien quel est
le montant fait des dons qui ont pu être
récoltés là aussi
les saint germanois ont
répondu vraiment présent on a eu à peu
près de 10000 dont le jour même et puis
surtout on a monté c'est ce que nous a
appris le coc vide des plates formes de
collecte avant et donc on a récolté 22
mille euros avant et puis on a les
virades scolaires aussi à saint germain
sur trois écoles qui ferait qu' on va
récolter à peu près 60 mille euros sur
l'ensemble en fait de la virade ce qui
est par rapport à la dernière peut-être
l année dernière c'était un petit peu
particulier parce qu'on était sous
qu'ovide et mais les années précédentes
on s'était encore une virade plus
importante donc on récoltait à peu près
cent mille euros medhat dans ce format
là 60000 euros ça serait vraiment
formidable et justement à quoi va servir
cet argent donc récolté est ce qu'il va
voir des investissements par exemple
alors vous savez que les virades de
l'espoir c'était nationale donc il y
avait un peu plus de 200 virades en
france et donc tous et dont la remontée
au niveau du siège et participants fait
au financement notamment de la recherche
puisque c'est vraiment le principal
objectif de de l'association il ya 3
millions d'euros qui sont dépensés
chaque année on est le premier financeur
en fait en france 2 contre la
mucoviscidose et donc tout cet argent là
sert à la recherche ser améliorer aussi
la qualité de soins des patients parce
que ils vivent maintenant on a cinquante
cinq pour cent des patients qui sont des
adultes qui peuvent être en situation
précaire et donc on est là aussi pour
accompagner les familles et les passions
ou qu'est ce que c'est ça on lisait tout
à l'heure on n'en guérit pas encore
aujourd'hui mais on peut améliorer en
fait la vie de ces personnes sont
atteintes de cette maladie même si on a
vécu un formidable moment cet été
puisque en fête a été mis sur le marché
en fait une trithérapie qui s'appelle le
caf trio et qui permet à 3000 malades
sur les 7500 de pouvoir bénéficier et
d'avoir une amélioration en fait de leur
quotidien donc ça c'est une vraiment une
première victoire et puis faut continuer
à se battre pour les autres qui peuvent
pas bénéficier en fait les greffés et
ceux qui en sont atteints en fait de
maladies rares pourrait effectivement
qui lui qui puisse bénéficier en fait
d'un futur traitement donc là il ya
vraiment de l'argent qui aura récolté le
combat continue contre la mucoviscidose
et pour aider ses passions l'art est
justement le combat continue on peut
encore faire des dons malgré que
l'événement - et lieu dimanche on peut
encore faire des dons via une plateforme
via le site qui s'affiche d'ailleurs en
bas de l'écran ww point virades des rois
point fr et vous allez sur le site et
vous pouvez encore donné et jusque quand
on peut donner jusqu'à la fin d'année
jusqu'à la fin de l'année dont jusqu'à
décembre exactement peut continuer à
faire des dons oui pour la recherche
pour la recherche parfait mais écoutez
merci beaucoup merci large d'avoir été
avec nous je le rappelle vous êtes
l'organisateur de la virade des rois qui
a lieu à saint germain en laye
[Musique]
la commune de montigny le bretonneux
organisé son dixième baby sitting ce
samedi matin à l'hôtel de ville encadrés
par le pôle jeunesse l'événement permet
chaque année aux familles en recherche
de baby sitter mais aussi aux jeunes qui
souhaitent garder des enfants de se
rencontrer une première prise de contact
en vue d'un contrat célia gâte sont
gaussés font du surplace regarder un
baby sitting destinée aux familles aux
jeunes iny montant à la recherche de
garde d'enfants les rencontres ont lieu
à l'hôtel de ville de montigny le
bretonneux ce samedi 25 septembre le but
faciliter la prise de contact il n'y a
aucune décision de prise ce matin c'est
simplement une prise de contact les gens
reprendre en contact par la suite et
nous dans les jours qui suivront nous
continueront d'accompagner les jeunes
nous leur ferons rencontrées par exemple
une éducatrice de jeunes enfants qui
pourra alors donner des éléments sur la
meilleure façon de prendre en charge un
enfant donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
à la fois d'un service donné aux
familles et donc d'une aide aux jeunes
mais aussi quelque chose de formateurs
pour les jeunes 56 baby sitter âgés
entre 16 et 25 ans se sont rendus sur
place pendant la journée la plupart
étaient étudiants objectif gagner de
l'argent mais aussi de l'expérience les
pères de la garde d'enfants pour avoir
des petits revenus pour les sorties les
petites choses comme ça ben pour la vie
d'étudiante et donc voilà c'est très
pratique pour les soirs les soirées de
garder des enfants j'aime bien de
m'occuper des enfants et que aussi comme
ça je peux faire un petit peu d'argent
de poche ça peut être régulier par
exemple juste une soirée par semaine ou
alors plusieurs soirées si je suis dit
reconnu par semaine c'est pas choisi
ouverte ou alors occasionnels par
exemple si les parents veulent sortir un
samedi soir ou des choses comme ça je
voudrais être professeur plus tard donc
c'est un première approche avec les
enfants et puis pour remplir ma semaine
qui est un peu vide est une quarantaine
de familles étaient présentes pour
trouver la perle rare on peut rencontrer
beaucoup de candidats et se faire une
idée en fait assez rapidement des gens
qu'on souhaite revoir par la suite et
après engager éventuellement moi je suis
ravi c'est vrai que les années
précédentes j'ai essayé de trouver comme
ça on se dit tiens on va aller au
restaurant c'est assez difficile de
trouver quelqu'un comme ça rapidement un
livret contenant les demandes des
familles étaient distribués aux jeunes
en moyenne par an et baby-sitters ont pu
prendre une dizaine de contacts
et pour approfondir le sujet de la garde
d'enfant je me trouve actuellement avec
awa camara bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes la directrice de la
microcrèche l'abeille le papillon
installé à montigny le bretonneux c'est
exact elle accueille notamment des
enfants jusqu'à jusqu'à trois ans on va
y revenir dans un instant pour parler de
votre structure mais en juste avant la
tant attendue dans le reportage c'est
difficile parfois pour les parents
d'accéder de trouver des baby-sitters
notamment de dernière minute même en ce
moment il n'y a pas actuellement tous
qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de place en
crèche vous êtes en contact du coup avec
ses parents qui essaye de faire
accueillir leur enfant par exemple dans
votre micro crèche pourquoi ces
difficultés aujourd'hui de trouver des
places écoutez il ya
des listes d'attentes parfois au niveau
des structures même s'il ya des
assistantes maternelles même si il ya
des gardes à domicile bah voilà le taux
de natalité je continue à se développer
et c'est pas évident selon aussi quand
l'enfant est né est ce que c'est en
début d'année en fin d'année des fois
les effectifs sont déjà pleins et puis
certaines crèches aussi accueille des
enfants par groupe d'âge ce qui peut
aussi peut-être mettre une liste
d'attenté supplémentaire pour les
enfants les parents concernés vous avez
beaucoup de parents qui viennent en vous
disant c'est notre dernier recours par
exemple on n'a pas trop de blister parce
que tout à fait alors il ya le terme
baby sitter qui est plus sûr de la garde
occasionnelle et quand les parents nos
contacts vraiment ils veulent un garde
un mode de garde qui soient pérennes et
avec des horaires qui correspondent à
leur emploi du coup on va revenir sur
votre structure la bei et le papillon la
microcrèche est ce que déjà vous pouvez
nous présenter cette structure vous vous
définissez en tant que crèche
microcrèche citoyenne et inclusive est
ce que vous pouvez nous parler du
concept oui tout à fait alors on l'avait
papillon c'est une entreprise qui a eu
le label et zus donc entreprises
solidarité solidaire par dont l'utilité
sociale nous sommes sur le pas du lac
depuis 2014 citoyenne et inclusive c'est
parce qu'on veut ouvrir nos portes à
tous les enfants peu importe finalement
leur situation qu'ils soient en
situation de handicap qu'ils soient
valides ou pour lesquels les parents
sont inscrits dans un processus
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
car parfois ses parents ne sont pas
prioritaires dans les modes de garde
voilà et nous sommes deux à gérer cette
structure maïmouna bac et la deuxième
que gérante et moi même et justement là
vous en parler un petit peu vous vous
proposez des solutions notamment aux
familles qui ont quelques spécificités
par exemple les familles monoparentales
ou ou qui ont des enfants atteints de
handicaps pourquoi s'adresser en
particulier c'est plus difficile pour
eux de trouver peut-être un accueil pour
leur semblait tout à fait si on revient
sur le sujet de l'insertion sociale et
professionnelle c'est des familles ou
parfois dans les modes dans les crèches
il faut un contrat de travail il faut
travailler pour pouvoir mettre son
enfant structure du coup ces familles en
général n'ont pas de contrat de travail
elles sont parfois en formation elle
tente une formation où elles ont aussi
parfois un projet d'insertion sociale et
professionnelle qui fait que le blésois
vont être décalés
with vont pas être tout de suite par
rapport à la demande mais pour trouver
du boulot il faut pouvoir avoir un mode
de garde pérenne donc oui il ya une
spécificité pour ses parents et pour les
parents d'enfants en situation de
handicap parfois l'école n'est pas
encore mis en place parfois la famille
ne travaille pas et un mode de garde
pour des enfants de moins de trois ans
atteint d'un handicap ou de maladies
chroniques c'est d'abord permettent aux
familles de souffler et aux enfants de
se socialiser et d'autres avec leurs
pairs et dont vous concrètement qu'est
ce que vous proposez comme solution pour
ces familles alors on a deux types de
solutions on a notre micro crèche qui
est situé au pas du lac et qui peut
permettre l'accueil de ces familles en
lien avec d'autres familles et on a
depuis peu un service de garde à
domicile qui s'appelle hors les murs et
qui permet en fait d'accompagner ces
familles à leur domicile ce qui est
aussi particulier dans ce dispositif
c'est qu'on a été soutenue par la dette
par la direction départementale de
l'emploi du travail et des solidarités
qui nous permet d'accompagner
particulièrement les parents les
familles monoparentales qui sont
victimes de violence conjugale ou non
mais qui vivent en centre d'hébergement
et de réinsertion sociale ou un mjt ce
qui permet vraiment d'avoir un suivi
très particulier et de pouvoir aussi
pondérer le coup avec une aide une
subvention pour aider ces familles à
accéder à notre service et surtout que
ça soit accessible et que l'argent ne
soit pas un frein et du coup cette
deuxième solution donc hors les murs
pourquoi vous avez lancé c'est ce que
vous avez ressenti un besoin justement
oui tout à fait lucide tout à fait déjà
ce avec sur la micro crèche nous on a
peu de place à une microcrèche est
jusqu'à dix enfants on va dire sur sur
la semaine chaque jour donc on avait pas
mal de demander une liste d'attenté est
en fait le besoin s'est fait encore plus
ressentir pendant le premier confinement
en mars 2020 ou vraiment ça devenait
urgent pour nous de trouver une solution
complémentaire pour des familles qui
avaient vraiment plus une mode de garde
pour des enfants en situation de
handicap qui se retrouvait sans solution
donc on a demandé des agréments pour
accueillir des enfants porteurs de
handicap de 0 à 18 ans ou des enfants de
moins de 3 ans par le même service par
la dette sans saignement la direccte et
du coup c'est vrai que pour nous il
semblait nécessaire de compléter notre
offre pour pouvoir répondre au plus
grand des besoins et l'actuellement donc
combien d'enfants vous accueillez et
comment ça marche pour vous contacter ce
qu'on peut encore vous contacter pour
faire garder ses enfants alors au niveau
de notre structure de la micro crèche
pour l'instant nous n'avons plus de
place on peut toujours nous contacter à
contacter @ abeilles papillons point fr
et pour le service de mode de garde à
domicile en septembre on a commencé et
on a déjà là quatre familles qu'on a
accompagné on a un petit peu de listes
d'attentes et on continue vraiment à
rencontrer les centres d'hébergement en
quelques mois on a rencontré une
vingtaine de centres d'hébergement donc
les demandes vont continuer je pense à
venir et pour nous contacter pareil il
faut pas hésiter via cette même adresse
contact @ abeilles papillons point fr ou
au 07 60 92 03 36 où on vous répondra et
on essaiera trouver ensemble une
solution et bien c'est noté merci
beaucoup à ouakam avant d'être avec nous
ce soir je rappelle donc vous êtes la
directrice de la bei et le papillon le
micro crèche qui est située à montigny
le bretonneux persie
[Musique]
un nouveau terrain de jeu pour le club
de bmx de voisins-le-bretonneux vendredi
dernier le police a créé sur la zac de
la remise a été inaugurée par à la maire
de la commune le président en 2 saint
quentin en yvelines et les présidents du
club ce pôle regroupe un terrain de
bicross un skate park et des vestiaires
un projet de longue date d'une longue
date par don financé en partie par saint
quentin en yvelines et ça va bien sûr
valoriser l'engagement de ces jeunes
peut-être à faire de la compétition 6 1
mais mais mais mais c'est vrai que pour
ses études c'est un loisir un sport
une passion aussi un vélo bien sûr 50
ans à devenir après la capitale du golfe
etc la ryder cup va devenir la capitale
mondiale du vélo et puis vaima la maj
chaves pour changer de sujet était dans
les yvelines ce vendredi 24 septembre au
programme un tournage pour la chaîne
youtube seb avec ta star la miss france
2010 9 s'est vendu à mon talent et le
bois au coeur de la nature pour
participer à un stage de survie
la jeune femme a par exemple appris la
cueillette appris à réaliser un abri ou
encore à faire du feu un défi lancé par
terre de scène pour promouvoir le
territoire en partenariat avec le
youtuber sébastien personnes vous
pourrez découvrir la vidéo début octobre
sur la chaîne youtube seb avec ta star
et c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis dans
quelques instants retrouvez mais quel
ennemi d'euros pour la présentation de
votre journal de sport à merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis très bonne soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]